Cecile Richards the maniacal ghoul who
for the past dozen years has run the
largest abortion mill in America is
reportedly stepping down from the
eugenics Factory and organ harvester we
will take a look back on the abject
misery Cecile leaves in her wake
then Liz wheeler and Arielle Davidson
joined the panel of deplorable zhh to
discuss president Trump's apparent
willingness to speak with special
counsel robert muller under oath trumps
vowing to cut off aid to the hamas
electing arabs in the fictional country
of palestine right next to never
Neverland unless they return to peace
talks and CNN advocating cuckoldry I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
coming in hot today chuckle dree we've
got abortion there is a lot going on the
Palestinians Cecile Richards appears to
be stepping down as the leader of
Planned Parenthood so let's have a look
back on the havoc wreaked by that
maniacal ghoul under Cecile's leadership
Planned Parenthood has killed 3 million
babies 300,000 per year 30 percent of
annual abortions as former Planned
Parenthood manager Abby Johnson points
out Richards has overseen a 51 percent
decrease in breast cancer screenings of
Planned Parenthood a sum total of zero
mammograms given despite the seals
public insistence that Planned
Parenthood gives out mammograms it does
not a 65 percent drop in pap smears
major drop in STD testing and a 670,000
640 patient drop since Planned
Parenthood shifted its focus away from
providing any health services whatsoever
entirely to killing babies during Cecile
Richards is reine Planned Parenthood has
also been exposed for refusing to report
statutory rape for aiding sex
traffickers for taking money explicitly
to kill black babies and for illegally
selling baby organs and body parts on
the black market for profit to the
highest bidder the FBI is now
investigating Planned Parenthood for
criminal actions hear or senior Planned
Parenthood officials Jennifer Russo
Deborah nuka-cola and Mary Gator caught
on hidden camera discussing their crimes
[Music]
very very trying to facilitate them even
like if it were to preach ultrasounds it
makes everything
everything out
[Music]
we've been $50 per specimen I think some
people are doing more some what would
you expect for intact a tissue what sort
of compensation what sort of the one you
start by tell me what you used to do you
know negotiate as a person who throws up
to figure first John Ross right sir I
wanna Lamborghini I want a Lamborghini
that's Planned Parenthood admitting to
negotiating to haggling over what price
should be paid for baby parts for and
for whole baby cadavers in in that
previous video a Planned Parenthood is
admitting to making sure that babies
come out whole cloth in fully intact so
that they can get a higher price for
them on the open market I wonder why the
Justice Department is investigating them
I wonder and it's funny how Barack Obama
didn't investigate them two years ago
when these tapes came out but there's a
new sheriff in town and now Planned
Parenthood is being investigated so what
else does Cecile Richards leave behind
is her legacy Martin O'Malley
the former shirtless Democrat candidate
for governor pushed in 2016 the
oft-repeated claim that 97% of the work
that Planned Parenthood does is about
mammograms and preventative health to
begin Planned Parenthood doesn't provide
mammograms absolutely none
Cecile Richards herself was exposed for
pushing this lie Planned Parenthood
arrives at that 97% number by Counting
each service no matter how small
separately so if a woman comes in for an
abortion
she might also have an STD test a
pregnancy test a foot massage a glass of
water some oxygen from the air smaller
services are each counted separately to
obscure that essentially the only thing
Planned Parenthood does is kill babies
speaking of water rich Lowry made a good
comparison forty five thousand runners
participate in the New York City
Marathon but two million cups of water
are handed out along the way
so by Planned Parenthood's logic the New
York City Marathon is mainly in the
hydrate
in business only 2.2 percent of what the
New York City Marathon does is award
medals to runners 97.8% of the New York
City Marathon services or passing out
cups of water so the New York City
Marathon it's on the marathon business
why would it be in the marathon business
it's in the hydration business stop
demagoguing Republicans or whatever they
say in reality when comparing the
prenatal services and adoption referrals
Planned Parenthood gives out to the
abortions that they perform it becomes
clear that 94% of Planned Parenthood's
work under Cecile Richards 'as watch has
been abortion now just a little bit of
good news before we get to our panel
here as of yesterday a pro-life lawyer
Alex a czar former clerk for Justice
Antonin Scalia has been confirmed to
head the Department of Health and Human
Services good news adios Cecile I hope
you're stuck in whatever cavern of Hell
spawn you for at least another thousand
years or so okay let's get to the panel
we have Liz wheeler you know her from Oh
a N and Arielle Davidson ladies thank
you for being here this is a lovely
antidote to yesterday's all-male panel
it's really nice to have you here
Liz we'll begin with you because we
don't have Ariel yet Liz what is the
future well we would start with you
anyway you're always on the front of my
mind what what does the future look like
for Cecile Richards
she's leaving Planned Parenthood she's
got this wake of dead bodies behind her
what's she gonna do run for president
run for the Democrat nomination for
president I I don't know I've been
shocked actually to see especially on
Twitter how many liberals are wanting
her to follow in her mother's footsteps
and run for governor of Texas here I I'm
actually talking about this on my show
tonight but the idea of legacy which is
what people are talking about when it
comes to Cecile Richards her legacy ten
years at Planned Parenthood the idea of
legacy is what you leave in your path
you know your footprints the mark you
make on this earth the legacy of this
woman is horrifying me everything that
you said about her is 100% accurate she
leaves a trail of blood behind her all
the money that she's made is Blood Money
and if I may if I may
stoop to a little bit of a conspiracy
theory here I'm talking about we
encourage it on this show yeah good I
thought you might like that
so I was writing my final point just
before my final point for my show that's
the sort of that monologue that I used
to close out my show at the end I was
writing that right before I came on here
and I'm talking about the legacy of
Cecile Richards as I close out my word
document to email it to my producers to
put into our programming to get it into
the teleprompter guess what the word
count was on my little legacy my little
overview of Cecile Richards what was it
six word tell me you know Liz all nature
is but art unknown to the all chance
direction which thou canst not see we
often find a lot of meaning in little
coincidences and symbols and certainly
you couldn't they couldn't write you
that any better than ending up with 666
it says a lot by the way about the
Democratic Party you know this this was
the party that not too long ago just as
recently as their most recent
presidential nominee said the abortion
should be safe legal and rare said that
we shouldn't have a ton of abortion and
now we have a woman leaving Planned
Parenthood clearly contemplating her
political future who not only encourages
rampant abortion but actually practiced
it is actually the reason that abortions
have increased so much at Planned
Parenthood what does that say about the
direction of the Democrats right no no
it's horrifying you're right they don't
advocate for safe legal and rare
abortion anymore they want it I mean I
don't think they care whether it's safe
because you look at this statistics it's
not a safe procedure certainly not for
the unborn child but not for the woman
who undergoes this abortion either they
certainly want it legal they want it
legal up until the moment of birth there
was actually we talked about on my show
a week or so ago there was actually a
student I think he went to the
University of Knoxville in Tennessee he
was advocating for abortion after birth
abortion up to two years of age because
he said until you get to that age you're
not quote unquote sentient there forth
you can't communicate how do we know you
can feel how do we know you can perceive
and therefore we as a society have a
right to do with you or do away with you
as they please and to be honest it seems
like he's maybe on the fringe but the
logic that he's following is the logic
that has been given to us by the left it
is what they are embracing they tell us
that we should not apply any stigma to
abortion that there's nothing wrong with
abortion there's so
side effects are consequences from
abortion they want a hashtag shout your
abortion at this point the Democratic
Party used to boast within its
membership many many people who were
pro-life and Democrats now we hear from
Tom Perez he's the chairman of the
Democratic Party that pro-life
candidates are not welcome in the
Democratic Party if you believe in the
sanctity of life if you think that
abortion ends a human life and kills a
baby you're not welcome anymore in the
Democratic Party that is as Extreme as
we've seen from the Democrats in I can't
tell you how long that's right they've
clearly moved toward advocating fourth
trimester abortions they've been moving
that way for a long time and this is an
aspect of the Democrats that used to be
so disingenuous at least now they're
sort of honest and open about it they
used to say this was the mario cuomo
line and it's been used by a lot of
ostensibly Catholic or Christian
Democrats ever since they say I
personally would never get an abortion
but I support a woman's right to choose
to get an abortion which is really
saying I would never murder my own
precious seed which will be so important
for this society and for my family but
all of those poor little black babies we
should all kill them that's what they're
saying that's the line of the Democratic
Party it's it is an essentially you you
so late all of these arguments brought
up in like Freakonomics they would say
well you know if there is more abortion
in inner cities there will be less crime
and less welfare dependency and I had a
great lunch once with the bioethicists
Diana Schaub the political philosopher
and she said which argument that these
lefties are positing for abortion which
argument could not be equally applied to
killing people who are or to killing
black people in the inner cities who are
committing crime and who are some people
who are on welfare what which of these
arguments could not be used for killing
people who are mentally [ __ ] which
of these arguments could not be used for
killing the elderly who are no longer
contributing to the American economy and
every single argument that these people
make for abortion when you look just
just past the surface becomes a whole
morally horrifying morally repugnant
argument we now have Ariel
very quickly before we move on past the
maniacal ghoul thank you for being here
what does Cecile Richards his future is
she going to be running for office
anytime soon I mean the problem is that
you're kind of touched on it and I
hopped in is that it had you know
abortion in general has become something
that's been I would say celebrated on
the Left quite extensively and I think
it was a very focal point a focal point
of the women's March I think it's become
something that they started a banner
under which the left has tried to
assemble as many progressive women as
possible so I think Richards
you know has amassed quite a following
in her and unfortunately in her ghoulish
stature she is definitely garnered some
national attention I just I sincerely
hope she doesn't run for office some
she's a horrible human being I hope that
this is the last that we see of her in
the public eye but who knows I mean I
think that she's a she's a mask
quite a bit of sinister pallor and it's
it's I would be curious to see what her
next move is quite honestly you should
probably serve in a few boards on the
left probably you know corporate boards
match is already on the Ford Foundation
board evil in high places principalities
and powers and the Ford Foundation one
thing I would say her legacy if you look
over the past 10 years what she's done
and what she's left in her wake Margaret
Sanger would be proud Margaret Sanger
started Planned Parenthood with a
eugenicist vision she started Planned
Parenthood yeah no question ting to
exterminate black babies that's what
Cecile Richards has done in her 10 years
at Planned Parenthood she talks about
women's health but if you look at the
statistics Planned Parenthood performs
less than 2% of pap smears less than 2%
of cancer screenings less than 2% of
breast exams 0% of mammograms but across
our country they performed 34% of
abortions that's millions and millions
of babies who have died under under
Cecile Richards while she's been leading
Planned Parenthood that's her legacy
broken lives broken hearts and dead
babies that's right if you read Margaret
Sanger's book woman in the new race it
is clear very often the left accuses us
of using spurious quotes saying that she
wanted to kill minority babies
and they say well she was being ironic
or she was saying this or that yeah
that's a hilarious joke but it's beside
the it's beside the point
it is so clear from her her famous book
woman in the new race that she
considered ethnic minorities and
immigrants a drag on the American
population and she says if women are
gonna give birth to the new race we need
to give them good stock to give birth to
and it's clearly eugenicist it's clearly
bigoted all right enough about Cecile
Richards has done her very proud now
she's gone enough abettor I don't want
to talk about those schools anymore
we've got so much exciting stuff to talk
about in the news president Trump has
signaled that he is not only willing to
testify to Special Counsel Robert Muller
under oath but that he is looking
forward to it Liz I love how the
braggadocio here I love the enthusiasm
is this a terrible idea or a very
horrible idea
yeah it's with all due respect to our
president it's a stupid idea for him to
testify under oath I understand that
he's playing the role of an innocent
innocent man here and given all the
evidence that we have not found in the
last year of investigations I believe
that the evidence shows that he is an
innocent man there's no evidence of
collusion between he and the Russians
between any of his campaign officials
and the Russians between any of his
administration officials and the
Russians but my question if I were
President Trump before I would agree to
testify in this special council
investigation is have you been operating
in good faith has your investigation
been operating in good faith has the FBI
been operating in good faith has the
Department of Justice been operating in
good faith if the answer to that is
anything other than a resounding yes
and we all know that it is a resounding
no I wouldn't I wouldn't get near that
with them with a forty nine and a half
foot pull because it's just a trap
they're just going to try to use his
words against him because they're trying
to build a case for obstruction of
justice and we know how our president is
with his words it's a little bit loose
with the language sometimes I'm willing
to admit and that's right you could
indict a ham sandwich
it sure looks like a trap Ariel is there
any chance Muller passes on questioning
Trump says he doesn't want to question
Trump and that Trump is really just
making a PR bluff here because he knows
he won't actually be called to testify
the question I would ask myself here so
is it a PR bluff does he know that he
won't have to testify or is it you know
just more of the impulsive Trump we've
come to sort of you know endearingly
expect right so and I heard that he made
this statement I immediately assumed
that it was a product of impulsivity I
suspected that perhaps he hadn't spoken
with his lawyers yet um so you know I I
would i wonder if this offer will even
last that long after Trump is sort of
perhaps you know talked out of it by his
own lawyer team you know this sort of
speaks of what we know we elected
initially which is we know we elected
someone who is not a politician and for
all of the you know sort of victories
that's garnered for us having someone
outside the DC Circuit it also means in
situations like this where impulsivity
seems to reign supreme in certain
situations where Trump is eager to show
to the public that you know I am an
innocent man I'm not even sure if it's
necessarily PR Stein or if you are
someone who's truly innocent you might
very well be eager to just say look
question me you know I know that I I'd
be happy to I'd be on it you know I'd be
glad to and so that was sort of the take
I had on it and I do think that even if
it is were to be perceived as a PR stunt
if there's any sort of genuine sentiment
behind it which is really just an
innocent man trying to say you know look
I have at it I'll tell you everything
you on yours I'm an open book
yeah that's an endearing that is that is
a good selling point and that does that
does I think if it really is inline and
consistent with Trump's past nature of
impulsivity I think it speaks actually
pretty well to his it the fact that he's
innocent
just then one point I find I I agree
with that largely one point I do find
though is on the impulsive 'ti Donald
Trump clearly gives the impression that
he's just shooting from the hip and he's
always impulsive but the case of Steve
Bannon makes me think there's something
more going on The Curious Case of Steve
Bannon who Trump knew was leaking when
he left the White House he knew was
saying bad things publicly about Donald
Trump he knew was speaking to this
tabloid writer Michael Wolfe and yet
Donald Trump didn't attack Steve Bannon
until months later until Bannon
was at his weakest point after the
Alabama Senate race that he totally blew
and when Steve Bannon publicly accused
Trump of treason then he finally hit him
but he actually held his tongue which
makes me wonder if some of Donald
Trump's insults and what appear to be
his rash reactions might be a little
more thoroughly thought out and
calculated them than not maybe I'm just
trying to fill the leftist tumblr
glass-half-full here I'm not sure on to
more exciting and happy Trump news
president Trump has vowed to cut off US
aid to Palestinians until they stop
disrespecting the United States and get
back to peace talks for those of you who
are not fans of fantasy fiction
Palestine is an imaginary country just
off of the coast of never-never-land
that nevertheless keep selecting
terrorists to govern them President
Trump said quote they disrespected us a
week ago by not allowing our great Vice
President to see them we give them
hundreds of millions that money is not
going to them unless they sit down and
negotiate peace
Liz why has it taken the us this long to
take such a strong and obviously correct
stand right and what an excellent
question this is Michael I'm not sure if
we're allowed to curse on this show but
it is about damn time it's all my
version here to cut off funding from the
Palestinian Authority I know your
viewers are highly intellectual people
but let me walk you through what happens
with the money that we are tax money by
the way that the United States gives to
the Palestinian Authority and I want I
want to make sure that that is clear
when we say the United States gives
money to the Palestinian Authority it is
our money the money our government takes
out of our paycheck every week so the
United States gives about three hundred
million dollars to the Palestinian
Authority in so-called aid every year
the Palestinian Authority then has
implemented this program which we will
call pay to slay it's called pay to slay
because it is exactly how it sounds the
Palestinian Authority pays terrorists to
kill Israelis Jews and Americans anybody
who does not agree with their radical
Islamic views they pay these terrorists
they pay them a stipend based off of how
serious of a crime they can commit the
more gruesome the murder the higher the
stipend they get paid if you murder in
Israeli your family is taken care of for
life if you
in jail you get a raise based off of how
long your sentence is all depending on
how grisly of a crime you commit Michael
guess how much money the Palestinian
Authority uses to fund their pay to
slake program I don't know
same amount of money that the United
States or the Palestinian Authority
every gosh oh my you know it's funny
because I often watch CNN or NBC or ABC
or read the New York Times in the
Washington Post so I haven't read about
any of that isn't that so strange Liz
that's very straight they don't seem to
report on this do they it is really
horrifying and and four years it's we've
only been listening to attacks on Israel
the only functioning democracy in the
Middle East the only liberal government
in Middle East the only government the
Middle East that respects the rights of
really any of its citizens and and these
the poor the Palestinian country it's
taught as though this is a nation-state
it's never ever been an Asian State they
elect terrorists as you say they pay
their citizens to slaughter innocent
people American allies and Israelis yeah
it's about time Ariel that little girl I
believe she was seven or eight years old
she was asleep in her bed in Israel when
a Palestinian terrorist a 19 year old
man climbed through her window and
stabbed her to death I'm sure she was
asking for it given you know given how
she occupies their territory given how
she wagers pre-emptive attacks on them
she certainly this eight-year-old child
clearly clearly she's a belligerent
right that's yeah that's clearly this is
within the confines of legal war right
absolutely
glad we're defunding his people Ariel
the consensus class are shrieking that
Trump has destroyed the so-called peace
process which is obviously generated
nothing but warfare and misery for
decades is there any chance that this
tough love is actually not only a good
way to strike back at these terrorists
but the most likely course for peace in
the region so I agree so I want to just
add on to what Liz was saying as well
it's that 300 million is about 10% of
the Palestinian Authority's budget so
they heard her every $10 they spend $1
is going to funding terrorist activities
and the other thing I will say so you
are adding you are asking is this going
to
help or is this going to assist the
peace process I absolutely 100% believe
it will
I think Netanyahu and Trump spoke
earlier today and precisely about this
fact and Netanyahu touched upon a very
interesting point which is you can't
really have peace without it being based
upon truth and the truth is that when
you when you when they moved the urban
they are deciding to move the embassy to
Jerusalem they are acknowledging reality
the United States is acknowledging that
Jerusalem is the eternal capital of
Israel they are not engaging in a new
sort of semantic warfare they aren't
engaging in any sort of slip of tongue
we are acknowledging fact we are
acknowledging reality only then after
acknowledging reality can you begin to
engage in a legitimate peace process so
when it comes to the Palestinian
Authority their inability to accept
reality is what has been very
detrimental to any sort of peace in the
region
and you know I think the other fact to
consider here is that you know Trump is
sort of taken away this fantasy if you
will that Jerusalem will never be part
of Israel and this has always been
something that sort of been dinked that
the Palestinian Authority and Hamas both
had dangled in front of their citizens
as a way of saying you know there's a
possibility there's a chance no there
isn't a chance there's no chance that
Jerusalem will not be part of Israel and
for the Palestinian Authority to
continue to dangle it and knowingly and
the deep down knowing that it's not a
possibility but still using it as a
cudgel to promote terrorist activities
it's something need dangling from their
citizens you know going back to what Liz
was saying what do you think the
emphasis beyond just monetary gain what
do you think the impetus is for someone
to you know go over and try to murder
Israeli citizens they believe that
there's a possibility that that Israel
will give up Jerusalem that's right
happy let them give up their whole
country that's right it is wonderful to
deal in reality yeah we had you need
reality is the prerequisite for for any
sort of negotiation and I think Trump is
is drawing serious lines and putting
reality into stark lights something that
Barack Obama refused to do only muddled
it up only
a further broad warfare to the weakness
okay we have still got to talk about
cuckoldry but unfortunately if you are
on facebook and youtube if you're not on
daily wire.com
you don't get to hear us debate the the
major issue
CNN advocating cuckoldry so sorry they
we're at this point now in in reality
where we can't tell parody anymore
reality has transcended parody and
that's where we are at CNN pushing
cuckoldry but if you're on facebook and
youtube you have to go to daily wire
comm if you want to hear the expert
analysis plus we have the mailbag to get
to and your lives will be changed so
make sure that you go to daily wire calm
right now what do you get you get me you
get the andrew Clavin show you get the
Ben Shapiro show you get the
conversation I believe I'm in that one
as for the next conversation everybody
can watch but only a few can ask
questions many are called but few were
chosen so you'll also get the leftist
here's tumblr now we have Trump at Davos
right now the global elite the every
elite self-appointed benevolent better
in the world is over there and I imagine
what he's going to do is smack all of
them in the face and hit their head
against the walls and then fly back to
America you're gonna need the leftist
tears this is going to be an
international outpouring of leftist
tears so make sure you get a protect
your family do not be caught unawares go
to daily wire calm right now we'll be
right back
ladies I'm a little embarrassed to bring
this topic up to you but it's important
I think that we have a panel of men and
women here to discuss this important
issue CNN is now advocating literal
cuckoldry CNN Headline today is
cuckolding can be positive for some
couples study says cuckoldry for those
who don't know doesn't just mean when
you vote for a moderate Republican like
Jeb Bush but it is more traditionally
when a wife cheats on her husband so
it's the oldest insult in the Italian
language you grow up hearing this all
the time the word coromoto is the sign
of the cuckold you see in in rock music
yet this sign those are the horns of the
cuckold sometimes you'll see little old
men from southern Italy wearing a gold
necklace that looks like a little chili
pepper that is the Horn of the cuckold
it's it's that's because in old Italian
culture that's the worst thing that
could possibly happen it's the same
thing as the evil eye the worst insult
us to call somebody at coromoto so
anyway
CNN advocates this now according to a
new survey 58% of men fantasize about
their wives sleeping with other men and
obviously the survey only pulled John
Kasich supporters but oh I don't know I
haven't looked into the numbers on the
survey but that's just what I assumed
I'll have to look into it further also a
third of women surveyed apparently
fantasized about cheating on their
husbands Arielle is this a sign of the
times or have men and women always been
self-destructive sex freaks the term I
always thought of the Canterbury Tales
from Chaucer I think when he all he used
it that was sort of a motif he used in a
few of his tales as well so as you were
mentioning it's been around for quite a
long time this idea I never thought of
it as a you know fantasy when I was
reading his stories it was always it is
a nightmare marriage material gentlemen
if you're watching you found the one
woman who doesn't have these weird
fantasies C&M felt compelled to write a
defense of it I mean not to me in and of
itself the sort of bizarre right I
understand the word you know that
cuckold has been thrown around to refer
to different conservatives I get that
but CNN writing a piece suit i defensive
it just really struck me as utterly
bizarre and really just a
if this is what's become socially
acceptable perhaps a degradation of our
culture in some way if those polling
numbers are correct I mean that's fully
disturbing the survey by the way was
undertaken by the writer Dan Savage who
is some depraved sex freak who tried to
ruin Rick Santorum's career and just
like a little gadfly you know and CNN is
running this as though it's coming out
of the University of Oxford yeah this is
serious scientific study it's just
disturbing it's just I read it and I was
like this is really where our culture is
headed I mean we were totally done for
this is it was absolutely I was just
appalled also that it was put out you
know I expected for maybe a BuzzFeed or
slate but from CNN I don't know I mean
it's really grotesque I know you would
expect it to be even grosser if it's
being run on CNN live Liz we appear to
have a culture of kuck if you will but
I've always loved this insult especially
because of my half of my ancestry is
Italian I've heard these kind of things
for a very long time
I think it's a great insult now people
are saying the word [ __ ] or cuckold is
an insult is racist for some reason it
has racist connotations but I guess
everything in this culture is racist I
don't know is it okay to use the insult
[ __ ] or cuckold or carruth Oh what the
word [ __ ] yeah maybe
thank you for sending this topic to me
it was a waste of five minutes reading
that article in my first reaction when I
read this was it sounds like a lot of
these people who were polled watched too
much pornography if these are the types
of fantasies that they're having it's
disgusting it's messed up why it would
be racist I have no idea the only thing
this this term has been popularized by
the old right who as we know are racist
tend to be very racist they have used
that term in the last year or two to
describe anybody basically who doesn't
agree with their twisted views so in
that sense that's probably where the
connotations of racist I tend to I guess
not pay attention when the other side
hurls accusations of racism just because
they do it so constantly that it dilutes
the real term but I'm not sure if the
connotations of this word
early races that I know of right you
know I'm certainly not going to allow
the 50 white supremacists in America to
take away one of the finest insults in
any language they don't that's our word
okay I speak as a representative of the
Sicilian Americans that's our word buddy
okay and I think you're right about the
porn pornhub.com just one porn site
reported I believe 4.4 billion hours of
porn have been consumed annually in the
last few years 60% among Millennials so
yeah stop if you're starting to get
weird fantasies man turn off the porn
that is probably not good for your
health or your marriage or our culture
okay we have got to get into the mailbag
I'm very sorry ladies I could spend all
day with you very nice thank you for
coming to discuss Cecile Richards and
Trump and cockle tree and CNN it's been
very nice we'll have to have you back
Liz wheeler you catch her on Oh an and
Arielle Davidson you find her writings
all over the Internet's thank you for
being here let's get into the mailbag
okay so in the mailbag we have the first
one from Seamus hi Michael which is a
better combination of college majors
economics and English or political
science and economics English English
and economics as though if you're going
to have to major in any social science
only major in one social science I don't
really put a lot of stock into political
science I'm interested a lot in
political philosophy I think there's a
lot to be gleaned from studying the
ancients Aristotle and Plato the moderns
Machiavelli Locke Rousseau even much
more recent ones Edmund Burke
Michael Oakshott and so on but political
science I really don't trust that much I
think the social sciences are easily
manipulable and not terribly reliable
that includes economics by the way but
something like English studying English
will ground you in in a more real
discipline and a more real vision of the
world you literature is one of the if
not the most important way to enter into
a kind of accurate and fuller vision of
reality literature brought Andrew Clavin
to believe in God and to Christianity
history I think would be a good way to
do that too or mathematics or
harder science physics might be a good
way to do it
maybe you study economics because you
want to get a job at a bank or something
but study English alongside it I think
it will serve you a lot better in the
future than some Poli Sci degree Barack
Obama studied political science that's
all you need to know
next question from Jeffrey Knowles I
just read Genesis 10 through 11 last
night and in your opinion is Nimrod
perhaps the best name in the Old
Testament or should I withdraw my
judgment until I make it further in
Nimrod is an excellent name my favorite
Old Testament name I think is Joseph at
I've been trying to convince sweet
little Alisa to name our first child
Jehoshaphat it's not going very well a
Nimrod is good it's too bad though that
now in a Nimrod is considered synonymous
with idiot or [ __ ] the reason for that
so Nimrod in the Bible is a mighty
hunter before the Lord and there is an
episode from the 1930s of Bugs Bunny
where Bugs Bunny refers to Elmer Fudd as
Nimrod ironically because sarcastically
because Elmer Fudd is not a mighty
hunter before the Lord but now ever
since then people say Nimrod and it just
means more honor idiot very sad too bad
for Nimrod and for that mighty hunter
next question from Michael I always run
into a snag when debating welfare with
friends for Democrats they always point
to the fact that I have used government
assistance such as the GI Bill and
Medicaid which admittedly has helped me
greatly how can I take a stand against
welfare when I have personally
experienced its benefits
this is one of the most insidious
arguments by the left to shut down
debate they get you hooked on some of
these programs which you've already paid
into in which you've already obviously
which you've used that they're at your
disposal and then they say you'll be a
hypocrite if you suggest that there are
problems within those programs that they
need to be reformed or curtailed and
it's it's just a way of shaming you and
basically getting you on getting you on
the hook and then dragging you wherever
they want you to first of all not all
welfare is created equal so an
employment incentive for people who are
willing to risk their lives to serve our
country is different than Obama phones
that's a the GI Bill is different than
Obama phones but second the to have
nothing to do with one another you'd be
an idiot not to use programs that are at
your disposal if you've already paid
into these things our society has
already paid into these
and if you need medicator if you if
you're going to use the GI bill of
course do that you've served in the
military take what was a part of the
deal when you signed up which is a GI
bill to help out with education your
personal life has nothing to do with the
unsustainability and generational theft
of out-of-control entitlement programs
that have to be reformed or they'll go
bankrupt has nothing to do with whether
or not 100 percent debt to GDP is going
to be a drag on the economy or slow down
growth those are totally separate things
you shouldn't feel guilty at all about
using the programs that were part of the
deal that you signed up for and that has
nothing to do that should not in any way
try to cloud your clear judgment on
whether or not these programs are
sustainable or good for a society or
need to be reformed or curtailed next
question from Robert hi Michael I am a
big fan of your relationship advice very
lovely ELISA
sweet Lisa's not a big fan of my
relationship advice but you know
whatever I'll I'll see what I can offer
you I would like to hear your thoughts
on my current situation what are your
thoughts on girlfriends or wives going
out to dance clubs with their single
friends
my girlfriend's girlfriend recently
asked her out to a dance club my
girlfriend and I are both very Catholic
and holds strong Christian values I want
to say I trust my girlfriend and would
be okay with her going out but I don't
trust her friend who is someone that
recently went to the women's March and
has a different set of values you don't
say she is someone that is immersed in
the hook-up culture I would like to get
your perspective Thanks okay so I guess
the first question is do you trust your
girlfriend and you both have see the
world the same way okay that's fine then
the second point is that dance clubs are
awful especially unless you're single
unless you're single and are trying to
score or something dance clubs are like
the worst thing ever and even then if
you're a guy who isn't just like a giant
Hulk or football player or something
dance clubs are not your best bet you'll
do a lot better to pick up a chick
elsewhere that you can like use your
words or something so I guess the first
question is why does she want to go the
whole point of going to dance clubs is
to dance with other people and then
maybe go home with them so if your wife
isn't gonna do that probably she
wouldn't have a whole lot of fun doing
it I guess you could go with her I've
gone to plenty of clubs in my life and
even when I'm not in
prowling for ladies and that's okay that
I guess that can be fun but I guess the
real question is why would she want to
go I wouldn't worry too much is gonna
cheat on you you probably have other
issues that you guys should talk about
but the real question is it probably
just won't be that fun if you're not
gonna go get drunk and dance up on a lot
of guys and and hook up with people I
there isn't much of a reason as a single
person to go to dance clubs so do that
and I hope that my advice is not them
gonna force you to have to go to these
things do cuz they're not a lot of fun
there are a lot of other better
nightlife possibilities and bars and
places you can go to so sorry if I just
got you looped into a bad Saturday night
next question from Spencer to his Most
Excellent Majesty the king of trolls it
is undeniable that you bear an uncanny
resemblance to the young Michael
Corleone and Godfather parts 1 and 2
thank you and thank you for leaving out
part 3 my question is simple but
intriguing if your fictional Sicilian
counterpart is Michael does that mean
Clavin is Vito Corleone Marlon Brando
and what about Ben is he Sonny or
perhaps the family's lawyer Tom Hagen I
would like to hear your thoughts Spencer
so I guess just on Strictly ethnic
grounds if I'm I the sicilian american
fellow is michael probably been has to
be Hyman Roth right he has to be the Lee
Strasberg character he's got to be the
Jewish gangster I don't know I haven't
really analyzed one for once um some of
it breaks down the one thing I do know
is that Marshall is Fredo that goes
without saying Marshall is Fredo
Corleone and we'll have to build the
movies all around that next question
from Hendrick on if you're descended
from the Mayflower where your ancestors
also Puritans the much hated Calvinists
they were indeed so half of my family
comes is descended from hay flour lines
and northern Europe and Great Britain
and then the other half is from sardine
but it's coming over from Sicily so the
the waspy ones were indeed Calvinists
Puritans but and more importantly those
pilgrims were separatists so they were
separated from England and then they
separated from Leiden when they thought
their kids were getting a little bit too
Dutch they were wearing too many clogs
or something so dear grandpa Samuel
fuller would certainly be scandalized by
my Pope
but I only had one pilgrim ancestor the
three other Mayflower ancestors were
strangers the so-called strangers they
just came along for the ride but they
weren't religious zealots they were not
pilgrims is one way to put it they were
just derelict it's all three of them one
of them John Billington was the first
person in the Plymouth Colony to be
executed for murder
they were rogues and knaves and navies
rogues so perhaps it is that balance
that has instilled in me from a young
age the important maximum of st.
Augustine Lord make me chaste but not
yet next question is from Brenda mr.
Noles
why do you say Protestant revolution
instead of the more Protestant
Protestant Reformation is it because as
a Catholic you disagree that the church
was in need of reform Thank You Brenda
and the church is always in need of
reform and no one has ever doubted that
I don't think I Pope Francis and perhaps
Pope Benedict suggested that I think was
Pope Benedict suggested that the devil
is in the Vatican the devil is there and
which is not not much of a surprise
given that we've just had two of the
greatest man of the century Pope John
Paul the second and Pope Benedict the
16th and the devil gets a little feisty
and wants to tear things up their
scandals banking scandals sex scandals
so is in need of reform the reason I use
revolution is I think that that term is
just much more accurate on the surface
the Protestant revolution was not a
Reformation it did not reform the the
church it it was a schism it broke away
from the church and created new sects
and denominations of various variations
on Christianity but it wasn't a reform
movement perhaps it began as a reform
movement but Luther left he and then he
was excommunicated and he wrote terrible
things about the church and vice versa
so it just doesn't count as one I got
the idea to call it revolution from the
historian Jacques Barr ISM the great
historian of of Western civilization and
also here were a wonderful book on the
modern era called from dawn to decadence
and the reason it really ought to be
called revolution is that it in many
ways kicked off the modern era it was a
worldwide revolution it dramatically
changed the course of history it wasn't
a mild reform
some liturgy or liturgical practice or
some political aspect of the church it
was a major break and it caused a lot of
chaos at the very least in the history
of the West and so I think you have to
refer to it as as a revolution next
question from Patrick dear Michael
Knowles king of trolls a while back you
spoke briefly about the early American
holiday of training day this is a wonder
what a holiday what a good this is a
good question to end them in which
colonists would go and eat drink and
shoot guns I've looked for a wild but I
can't find any information on it
can you give us some more specifics it
would be a shame for such a
quintessentially American holiday to be
forgotten and wonderful if it could be
revived thank you and love the show
absolutely the early new england
settlers beginning in the 17th century
held training days six times per year I
believe and it wasn't all frivolous it
wasn't just having fun training days
were largely serious occasions making
sure that they could put musket ball
warheads through King Philip for heads
and various things like that they had to
make sure that they were ready to fight
in case the Indians got a little feisty
as they intermittently did lots of
shooting a lot of cleaning arms prizes
were awarded silver cups and
handkerchiefs and things like that for
the best shot that went on about six
times a year following all the fun there
would be dinners held in public squares
and it was more festive eventually
though is the colonists became more
prosperous these training days I gave
way to muster day in which various
militias
would parade and compete with one
another even after the Indian Wars there
would be wrestling matches there would
be various drills the old men and young
boys and all of the women would judge
and see who was the best shot root for
who they wanted from the sidelines it
became a far more decadent affair than
training days they had eating booths and
tent shows and auction carts and candy
stands in New England rum selling for
three cents a glass so those exercises
lasted around until 1855 as the country
then prepared to actually slaughter one
another rather than merely wrestle and
drink rum and that was the end of a
training day but you know it's been a
century and a half since then maybe we
could revive that they'd be a lot of fun
so get on that maybe we
mez another thing to look forward to in
2018 okay that is our show
now obviously the another Kingdom is out
all 13 episodes are out that's my
narrative podcast with Andrew Clavin
where I play a thirty-year-old schlubby
guy in Los Angeles who can't get a job
in the entertainment industry no idea
why he would cast me for such a part and
then he fault walks into another Kingdom
through a portal and he's in this world
with ogres and horses and knights and
ladies and a bloody dagger and a dead
damsel at his feet so you can go and
binge that I really would really help us
out we're still pitching this at pretty
big places around town and we get to go
in there and say we've got almost 2,000
five-star reviews and we've got a
gazillion downloads and you have to put
us out there and then they say but
you're conservatives we want to tar and
feather you and you say well you have to
anyway dammit
so let us please help us to put a fork
through the eye the executives in
Hollywood leave a five star review
download sense your friends would be
very helpful one other thing this is
like a very minor almost stuff I like I
just started reading the David Bentley
Hart new translation of the New
Testament it is really illuminating
really interesting if you are if you've
already listened to another Kingdom over
the weekend check it out it's pretty
cool and we're gonna try to get him on
the show later on okay I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
try to survive the weekend and we'll see
you on Monday
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer Mathis Glover
our technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex zingaro audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Jeshua of era the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing
2018